To get some practice using navigation
controllers and storyboard,
we're going to build
a Make Your Own Adventure app.
It will look like this.
It begins with the first
line of a story and
the user gets to choose
what happens next.
So here we've got a tiger and
I think she should stalk to the door and
peek down the hallway.
So we press that button and
it leads to the next part of the story.
Let's work through
the steps to make this app.
Even though this app
will have multiple views,
I'm starting with the single view
template, because it's the simplest.
The first thing I'll do is delete this
View Controller that was automatically
generated, then I'll drag
in a Navigation Controller.
If you look in this automatically
generated Root View Controller,
you'll see that it has a Table View.
But we don't need a Table View for
this app, so let's go ahead and
delete that as well.
Then drag in another View Controller and
we're going to set that to
be the Review Controller.
I do that by bringing up the pop-up
menu for the Navigation Controller and
dragging this Root View Controller
property to this View Controller I
just brought in, then I drag in
a Text View for the story text and
two buttons for the choices.
Making sure to set the appropriate
constants of course.
This view is the first in a series
that have the same UI components.
So, once I have this text view and
these buttons setup the way I like them,
I'm just going to copy and
paste the whole View Controller.
I can do that by drawing a rectangle
around the View Controller like this.
Careful that second View Controller
appears right on top, but it is there.
Once we have our two
new View Controllers,
we can add some more text for
the next part of the story.
To segue way from one screen to the
next, I bring up the Connections menu
for each button and
add a triggered segue, like this.
Let's run it and
see what we've got so far.
Hm.
I'm getting a black screen.
That's not what I want, but
I have a guess at why it's happening.
I need to make sure my Navigation
Controller is set as the initial
View Controller.
So, I go into my
Attributes Inspector and
I click this is Initial View Controller.
Let's try it again.
Okay, much better.
So you can see I need to adjust my to my
constraints a little bit on the buttons,
but we've got a good start to our story.
Now repeat these steps on your own and
for more details and
notes on how to polish up the app,
consult the upcoming reading node.